the two Atlanta police officers charged
in the death of Rashard Brooks have been
until 6 o'clock tonight Eastern time to
turn themselves in fired officer Garret
Wolfe who prosecutors say shot books
twice in the back faces 11 charges
including felony murder officer Devin
Brosnan is charged with aggravated
assault and other crimes
last night demonstrators staged asleep a
so called dying is what they're calling
it outside Police Headquarters the
department says it was experiencing a
higher than usual number of officers
calling out for their shifts mark
Strassmann is following this part of the
story in Atlanta where the DEA is
calling the officer's actions excessive
just about here Tameka Miller is Rashad
Brooks widow she listened in as Paul
Howard the Fulton County District
Attorney explained something why he's
charging to Atlanta police officers you
certainly can't fire a gun a handgun
someone who is running away Howard has a
mountain of evidence eight videos of the
shooting and ten witnesses
Brooks chased by Rolf fired a Taser at
him world fired back with his gun three
times but investigators concluded Brooks
was not a threat at the time that the
shot was fired the utterance made by
officer Roth was I Gavin
Howard also pointed it out how the
officers behaved right after the
shooting officer Roth actually kicked mr
Bruce while he laid on the ground while
he was there fighting for his life the
other officer officer Brosnan actually
stood on mr. Brooks's shoulders while he
was there struggling for his life after
that announcement howard walked up to
protesters who had gathered outside his
office
get the opportunity to turn themselves
in
Howard explained
[Music]
before prosecutors announced the charges
Garrett Rossiter Neil and Lauro so spoke
to Atlanta CBS affiliate WGCL he
defended Ross actions by attacking
Brooks we are dealing with somebody who
has violently assaulted two law
enforcement officers has manifested his
intent to disarm a law enforcement
officer and proves to be a danger to
anyone in the area the attorney
representing Brooks is family says
charges are just the first step
justice will take convictions for
Brooks's family including four children
realize nothing will bring him back
Father's Day is coming up and all I can
do is just think about what if my
husband was still here you've already
heard that rafter the DA announced
charges that many police officers here
called in sick but the Atlanta Police
Department denies reports that many
police officers in every zone walked off
the job in protests and insisted the
city is safe but Gail no question this
department has a morale problem right
now a lot of cities do with their police
departments but certainly it's very very
heavy in Atlanta thank you very much
mark